the UNC offensive coordinator the former
Texas Tech head coach for those who
didn't see you play quarterback in
college cliff who would you say you sort
of tried to emulate I was a huge Joe
Montana fan growing up and I wasn't
anywhere near Johan Tana but the way you
played the game how smooth he was in the
pocket kind of his body control that's
somebody I always tried to emulate and
failed miserably at being as good as him
but that was my all time guy did you
meet him I've never met him that's
that's on the bucket list so hopefully
I'll get to do that one day would you
ask for an autograph or a picture
I'd go picture I'd go Pacer now I also
saw where you were nervous to meet Mike
Tyson another one of your guys that you
sort of idolized or admired we just had
him on last week and he's still kind of
intimidating what what did you think
when you first met Tyson yeah I mean
that he was like the nicest dude ever
but when he walks in I mean you think
he's huge I mean he's a big man you know
big head arms traps and so the more
cocktails we had at this racing event
the more it seemed like a good idea to
go say hi and get a picture but the
great dude very friendly and was was
very accommodating when'd you become a
boxing fan it really just watching him
growing up obviously Mike Tyson's
punch-out when all the time great video
games and we got into it and we have you
know watching parties on pay-per-view
pad ton of money to to watch it back in
high school uh did you get a Super Bowl
ring when you were with the pinhead oh
you did I did
no.3 yeah I was on injured reserve but I
was I was there and got to watch Brady
do his deal was awesome did you know at
the time how great Brady could be I've
never seen anything like it you know you
get there as a rookie and I remember
thinking to myself like I don't know if
I could ever be close to this guy no
matter what happens
when you get to watch on a daily basis
to work she puts in just how in command
he is of every aspect of his training
and mental approach it's it's insane and
and so you could sense there was
greatness on the longevity I don't know
if anybody could have anticipated that
but you could tell on a daily basis that
he wanted to be the best ever how often
do you wear your Super Bowl ring um when
I was the head coach would be sitting
prominently on his head and we had a
Richardson that was about that without
it it's pretty gaudy so I don't I don't
break it out too much
give me a Tom Brady story oh goodness
the most recent one was at a wedding at
Baker's Bay which is phenomenal kind of
Golf Resort in the Bahamas and we're all
there when our friends get married and
it's like Friday night everybody had a
long night weddings on Saturday I wake
up I'm checking out the island
struggling just to get out of bed tell
your golf cart around I see this cat
like by himself in this field and I'm
like what is going on with our pull-up
and it's Saturday morning like May and
Brady is out there with his assistant
doing resistant BAM
Raza throwing this is no kidding in this
like magical resort toast long night of
you know the pre-wedding party and
getting his work in and throwing the
football and doing all these dry and it
was just insane and this is your
whatever you know 18 for them it still
has that type of discipline and work
ethic that's cool
Kliff Kingsbury the UN co-offensive
coordinator former Texas Tech head coach
joining us what happened to Texas Tech
why did you lose your job you know I
think that's a great question I think
I'm still reflecting on that but you
know had an incredible run corel cut
gave me six years to try and you know
get us to that next level and so like
you know we had made strides but didn't
quite get where we needed to get and so
as I kind of reflect the next few months
I'm going to try to figure that out and
when I get another opportunity try to
try to do a little bit better job than
we did this this last time why take the
job at USC and why take it now
yeah I think when you see the
opportunity here it's such a storied
program storage physician coach Ellen is
phenomenal man treats players and
coaches really really well and just you
know that there are five and seventeen
that I think the sky's the limit and I
think with the talent on this team
sometimes when you when you have a
season like that you can refocus and use
it as motivation and I feel like it's
kind of the perfect storm to get out
here and do what we do offensively and
try to help coach helden and this
university get back to it where we all
want it to be how close were you to
joining the rims close I really have a
ton respect for Coach McVeigh and what
he's done you know great dude who treats
people the right way innovative on
offense high energy would have loved to
see you know on a daily basis how he
does things and would have tried to
contribute any way I can but just felt
like this was it was the right spot for
me at the right time I just wondered
though because it feels like your name
is still out there
you're still a hot property even though
you lost your job but for the NFL so
that's why I didn't know the timing wise
of you know you looked at the Rams and
then decided to take the USC job and I
was wondering about the the pro
possibilities and how you sort of
factored that into your decision yeah I
think you know that's something that as
I go on my coaching career definitely
has always played in that league you've
been fastened about badly and how
offenses are evolving you're seeing more
college type things going on but this
opportunity was just too great to pass
up with the talent we had here great you
know city to live in and work and so
what was happy to join coach Sheldon
so you had Johnny Manziel for a year at
a.m. you had mahomes how many years did
you have Patrick I had him for three
okay and I wish I thought Adams before
I'd still and then Baker Mayfield came
through as well but he was injured and
then transferred to Oklahoma right okay
but the most natural talented
out of those three mahomes men's
in Baker you know all three had
ridiculous traits yes you would like
Johnny's playmaking ability his quick
twitch making people miss his kind of
sense of spatial awareness was was
insane Baker phenomenal you know
accurate big-time arm cerebral cat who
its you know he could just diagnose the
defense as good as anybody
and then tat you know the ability to
throw from those different angles and
arm dexterity and move in different
platforms and see the entire field so I
was just very fortunate to work with all
three and each one had had things that
they did that are as good as anybody's
ever done in the history of football
really ever seen a better arm then
mahomes I have not not with you know the
touch you throw in there there may be
guys that can throw it and I get I think
he throws him throw it 85 yards probably
but not with a touch of different angles
the accuracy you know wherever his feet
apart pointing it doesn't matter he can
get it anywhere for just a natural arm
talent throwing ability and that was
from day one when I got around him he
could always throw it from any angle be
accurate and have great touch which is
so rare I would watch I would watch
Texas Tech just because of mahomes and
then I would come in on Monday and tell
my guys I said I don't know if this guy
can play in the NFL but it feels like
he's just sort of having fun directing
you know the offense and you gave him a
lot of freedom I don't think it was that
or was it yeah I think we just have one
like that there's a fine line of pull on
those reins and we tried to give him
stuff he had a great high school coach
there in whitehouse Texas and ran a
similar offense we're getting a lot of
freedom to check things up the line and
see leverage and just be him and so we
kind of kept that rolling and worked on
a few things but when you have one like
that that's that talent said you you
just don't want to screw him up kind of
get out of the way and let him go and
you see I think coach Reed give him a
lot of those same freedoms you know
what's amazing about Pat is with his
style of play how few turnovers he
really has because he's high
grows consistently on the move doing
things that traditionally you were told
not to do and he continues to make it
major work what do you see in your new
quarterback JD Daniels at USC haven't um
you know studied a ton of them but very
cerebral young man the fact that last
year should have been a senior year in
high school and he was playing in the
pac-12 and starting at USC says enough
about the kid so I'm excited to get
around him another quarterbacks and
start in selling on offense and see
where we can take this thing I know that
you get this all the time it's not a bad
thing to get that you know your
look-alike is Ryan Gosling do you think
Gosling that people come up and say they
think he's Kliff Kingsbury now hopefully
one day we'll get there had a wildly
successful career if we ever flip that
script but you're gonna invite him to a
game give them a headset and then you
walk around and then they might go oh
look at Gosling over there and and it'll
be got you know he's gonna be the one on
the headset so then we may be able to
make that happen out here I don't think
he was coming to Lubbock Texas but the
road here the Coliseum do you do you did
you use your charm a little bit though
when you recruited I don't know about
charm but you know if you have to and to
find out that one of the players moms
was a bigger fan than most and you know
he had to work the angles wait well how
do you work the angles here so you walk
into the living room yeah I mean just
say hey I can you know see where your
son gets his good looks
one line to get it going
did it work though I mean I lost my job
I think it'll work in LA though cliff so
hey congrats on the opportunity there we
look forward to seeing what you do with
that offense we appreciate your time
thanks so much Danny I'll take care
that's Kliff Kingsbury for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel two
three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]